this morning firefighters are making
some progress in their battle to contain
the fire threat to california's giant
sequoias the washburn fire in yosemite
national park is now 22 percent
contained as firefighters work to
protect some of the largest and oldest
trees in the world so far it has burned
more than four square miles of historic
parkland yosemite is partly closed
because of the fire and hundreds of
people have been evacuated jonathan
vigliotti is there
the fire fight in yosemite rages on
time lapse video shows the thick plumes
of dark smoke that triggered air quality
alerts over the entire region reaching
the bay area and as far north as oregon
despite flames being attacked from all
angles the washburn fire continues to
expand we are getting as many resources
as we possibly can we have tankers we
have helicopters we have dozers but the
safest way to fight the fire is also the
most difficult on foot in some cases
firefighters have had to hike more than
a mile in ash like this to reach the
flames it's all part of a multi-faceted
effort to save these national treasures
the giant sequoias are known for being
fire resistant but even they have a
limit you'll look up and you'll see
200 foot flame lengths and that kind of
fire is why they are less resistant to
survival in the past six years over 85
percent of the giant sequoia habitat in
the sierra nevada has been hit by
wildfire compared to just 25 percent the
previous century while the worst of the
washburn fire is moving away from the
sequoias it's now burning in a remote
area of the park that's hard to reach
fire crews are now re-strategizing
they're starting small fires known as
back burns to try to coax the flames
down the hillside the crews will go up
to the actual uncontrolled fire's edge
and they'll start working off of that
uncontrolled edge bringing fire down the
slope
and around 500 giant sequoias are still
threatened this morning some are 3000
years old fire crews are now working to
establish a perimeter around them they
also put down a water sprinkler system
we reported on this yesterday park
rangers tell me this is the first time
they've had to use this technique
in the entire park's history
gail
jonathan thank you we all want the trees
to survive